foreign
in Albuquerque the 505. what's up Justin
hey John how you doing I'm good my
brother what are you doing
I'm just uh taking a break from shooting
some horses so [ __ ] that a boy dude
shooting some horses man
out there in New Mexico good for you
brother
yeah so uh but my question is um I guess
I wrote it down it says I'm struggling
with uh my sexual relationship with my
wife I obviously want to have a good one
but I have internal struggles and I feel
a pavlovian response of Shame when it
does come to
um sex even practicing desire feels a
little bit uh shameful for me but when I
uh but then I feel very lonely and
robbed of connection because of that and
so I'm just kind of at a loss of what to
do for sure man dude uh have you ever
said that out loud before
yeah quite a bit
well thanks for making me one of many
that you've said that out loud too so
um when you say shame well let me back
up you said obviously I want this
um that sounds like something that
somebody told you you're supposed to
want
so I would take obviously off the table
is it something that you want
yeah I I would like that okay I don't
know I just feel
um
I just feel very robbed and I was of
connection and I when I got married I
was I was 21 and uh that's just been not
what I expected and I've been trying to
make the best of it I just don't know
what else to do there you go
um so tell me what shame means what does
that feel like where does that come from
I think well I know for a fact that it
comes from when my parents my parents
got divorced when I was really young and
the only uh and they were both
emotionally absent even though they were
kind of there they were just absent
altogether and so the place that I found
connection at a really young age was
pornography okay and so I was been
struggling you know obviously with that
for
um most of my life and so when I did get
married and I I expected that that
connection to be filled
um you know I turned into my wife's uh
trash can of all her complaints and and
struggles and stuff like that so then I
felt
um I wasn't being heard or or I was just
kind of a trash can as well and so I
I've continued to
um
use that pornography as that that way of
feeling connection so I can get through
uh to the next day okay
does your does your wife know um
there's my wife now
yeah we've we've been talking and we're
trying to work through it since uh
before we got married
uh how long have you been married
five four years four years okay does she
know you're still
um using pornography to get through the
day
yeah well not it's not every day but it
just you know when life gets tough now
it just it it seems like this yeah okay
um
hmm
there's several places we can go with it
um I I may be way out to lunch here so
sometimes somebody experiences sexual
abuse
um somebody get experiences pornography
at a really young age
and
sex gets lumped in with
I'm dirty right and yeah or kids who
masturbate a lot like or just one right
I'm dirty I'm gross and that gets
translated to when I get married or when
I get into a sexual relationship with
somebody I trust and that I'm with for
the Long Haul
that will all go away and it stuns
people
when they roll over and their bodies
they go right back into the I'm gross
and shameful right or they try to cover
themselves up right it becomes a part of
them right
yeah
um
that's about sex but it's also not
okay so trying to deal with just the sex
part of that is gonna
it's not ever going to get to
why doesn't Justin like himself
and
also
why can't Justin let his needs be heard
by his wife
and why can't she let her needs be heard
by her husband and why can't we stumble
and fumble and practice meeting each
other's needs in ways that we've never
had to do ever before
does that make sense
yeah I think it does that's a different
conversation than I feel gross after
being with my wife or I feel unfulfilled
yeah right does that make sense yeah it
does yeah okay so
the first thing in becoming a new person
right coming up with a new identity this
is who I'm gonna be
is stopping the behaviors
that like Do no harm right I don't know
what to do next but I know to stop doing
this
yeah and tell me what you feel like when
you are starved for connection what does
that feel like in your body
I just feel very uh lonely and uh
easily irritated because I just feel
very uh uh just I get super depressed
and um
I start questioning a lot of things and
what's that
like questioning I mean I honestly I I
question you know
um just because it it's good it's
happened over and over again I just uh
shouldn't like the purpose of life and
stuff so
there's more to that keep going
you're being honest with me don't Don't
Fade Out On Me Now
uh I am
I think that uh
I don't know I just have a lot of
anxiety in my chest right now but a lot
of times I uh
when it does come to this it goes
zero to a hundred then feeling uh
suicidal and not not that I'm going to I
just I just I felt so uh
lonely for so long I just don't know
um
I just I just want that connection and
so uh yeah I just feel very
like why why am I here if this is what
life is gonna be like there you go
thank you for saying that out loud
yeah
you've probably had a lot of
conversations about pornography a lot of
conversations about sex a lot of
conversations about hey all you do is
come home and complain to me about your
life
when's the last time you sat down and
looked another person in the eye and
said I'm super lonely and I don't know
what to do
conversation okay
um on Sunday
and um
I I felt I felt heard
but at the same time it
um
you know it kind of goes back to just
how we've been living
um right here's the deal
this is y'all are at a place now where
you've exceeded your capacity to do this
on your own
yeah okay and this is about your life
this is about your joy
and purpose and role it's about your
marriage it's about your family tree
it's about all of it okay
yeah and this is a backyard project that
y'all got to dig in with shovels and all
of a sudden you realized we're sitting
on top of a huge sinkhole we need to
call Professionals in here
because you all can have deep meaning
conversations and I'm proud of you
for Sunday saying
I'm so lonely I don't think I want to be
here anymore I'm proud like that's hard
to say those words out loud
but you say that out loud and neither of
you have the skills to then go okay what
do we do next
what does that look like next
um
you go you just fall back into right
what we've been doing because we don't
know what to do like you see what I'm
saying it's like it's like driving in an
ice patch you start spinning if you
don't already know how to turn into the
spin and how to take your foot off the
gas without hitting the brake and all if
you don't know how to do that
you just keep your foot on the on the
gas and that thing spins faster and
faster until it flies off the bridge
right
yeah
so
what you need today is to reach out to a
professional
and your community and if you got to
drive drive
if you need to get connected with
um like my friends at better help when
you do it online do it online
okay you have reached you're you are
shoeing a horse right now and you just
realize there's a massive foot infection
you need to call a veterinarian that's
what just happened okay
okay I will tell you
um shame is universal across all
cultures and helps us stay aligned with
our groups okay and if it gets out from
underneath us
the if you do something that violates
your core values right and your picture
of who you should be your identity if
you do something you're bi you're going
to feel shame and I'm okay with that
it's when it turns into it becomes the
shame becomes something that becomes a
part of us right or you've heard me talk
about the bricks if you do something
that violates your core values you're
going to pick up a brick you're going to
hold it I did this thing it's when you
put that brick in your own backpack and
say this isn't something I did this is
who I am
okay right and you have to get out of
the I am language
and come up with a new I am
I am a guy who's going to Steward his
mind and his body
I'm a guy who's going to Steward his
marriage
not I'm a guy who's going to quit
looking at porn
okay see what I'm saying yeah it's a
much different proposition to say I'm a
guy who just takes care of his body and
part of that is not just not putting
trash in my mind
I'm a guy who stewards relationships so
that when I start feeling lonely I feel
it way on the front end and I tell my
wife hey I'm feeling disconnected and
we've already met with a counselor and I
know she knows disconnection for me is
sexual it's it's intimacy right I miss
being with you
and some people loneliness means I miss
just sitting and talking with you and
sometimes couples have one of them
disconnection is sexual one of them's
disconnection is is conversational one
of them is disconnected I just want you
to hold me whatever that looks like is
fine
it's being able to have that language in
your relationship and she knows it's not
her fault or maybe part of it it doesn't
matter cool then tonight we're going to
be intimate tomorrow we're going to
knock off work a little bit earlier
whatever that look you see what I'm
saying we're gonna create some language
in our house because
not because we're trying to quit we're
trying to quit Justin from looking at
porn no
because we're a couple that stewards our
marriage
there were a couple that stewards our
bodies I just eat right not because I'm
trying to cut carbs I eat right because
on on me I'm a guy who takes care of his
body see what I'm saying yeah it's a
totally different proposition right so
I want you to remember this with all of
your heart
it's from the great brene Brown the
shame researcher
shame eats secrets for breakfast is how
she says it
if you have secrets in your marriage and
in your home and in your friend
relationships
your body it has a physiological
consequence it will cost your body okay
okay means when you're feeling
disconnected at the very front end and
you try to hide it from your wife and
you know once that that Domino gets hit
and it starts going and knocking all the
other dominoes down you know where this
ends up it ends up you wait for your
wife to go to the grocery store and then
you pull out the laptop and now you're
Off to the Races and you're already
feeling bad as it's happening but it
also you can't stop it right
yeah okay the moment you start feeling
disconnected on a Tuesday instead of it
waiting until Thursday or Friday you
tell your wife I'm starting to feel
disconnected
okay that's Secrets okay and she is
going to learn
through professional counseling that
y'all two are going to go to together
y'all are gonna learn
um
you're gonna learn how to hear that
those needs from each other without it
setting off your alarms now you
mentioned your parents you come from a
house where you're neglected
they had their own lives and you were
just a bother
okay
recognize in your body that it has
identified relationships as something to
be avoided because they hurt
you got a little boy inside of you that
for his whole life has been asking
what's what's wrong with me why wouldn't
they talk to me
there must be something screwed up
inside of me
is that is that fair is that right yeah
and now you have a need
and you're married you've got somebody
who's committed in front of her friends
and God I'm going to be here to meet
your needs and you're going to be there
to meet mine
and all of a sudden that relationship
alarm starts going off and you withdraw
and you go to
nameless anonymous
pseudo-intimate sources on the internet
because it's safer than entering into a
relationship because you did that once
when you were a kid and both your
parents said nah we don't want you
yeah right so here's the deal it's like
um
it's like you fell off a cliff into a
raging River and you almost drown
you still got to get out of that River
dry off but you have to have water that
night to drink because your body has to
have it to live right you can't just
avoid water forever you gotta have
relationships to be able to breathe
okay so you gotta teach your body that
relationships used to not be not be safe
not be okay now they are see what I'm
saying that's the journey you're on
you're gonna retrain your body same with
dealing with your horses that previous
owner abused you
I'm going to prove to you over time that
I'm not you're teaching that horse that
relationships are now safe because they
used to not be get what I'm saying yeah
you're that you're that horse okay
okay and so every time you feel your
body start to get annoyed at your wife
or get feel sharp with her
ask yourself what is my body trying to
protect me from
not okay why won't she you see what I'm
saying there's a total difference there
what oh I'm starting to get close I'm
starting to realize I need her right now
and my body's like oh no no no we're not
gonna do that again
and this is when you have to learn the
skills to go nope that's exactly what
we're doing we're going directly into
the into the mouth of this dragon
see what I'm saying
yeah absolutely it's something you
practice
um will you commit to 30 days
of staying off the computer
yeah I will
every time you
think you want to or you feel like you
need to I'll even go that far and need
to if you've been doing a long time it's
it's absolutely as as much as any
addiction as heroin is
um
will you write it down go to Walmart or
go to get on Amazon and order a cheap
Journal write it down here's what time
it was during the day here's what I feel
like
here's what's going on in my head as I
am feeling this call to do this and then
I want you to go for a run go for a walk
call a friend go do something go ride a
horse whatever okay
okay put on the calendar 30 days
okay Mark it off cool
yep all right well after this I want you
to tell your wife
um
you and I are gonna go see somebody and
I'm going to make the call for us would
she be in that into that for you
oh yeah yeah absolutely good hey you're
about to change everything
okay one more thing one more thing
Justin
do you promise
if you think about hurting yourself that
you'll call somebody
yeah absolutely
you promise promise
yeah yeah I don't believe you
yeah I promise that I'll uh talk to
somebody just because it's not I don't
it's not that I I want to be gone I just
want to feel um
feel loved yeah absolutely you want it's
not that you want to be dead that you
want the pain to stop
yeah
yeah
and by the way dude
you are loved
you're not you're not loved in a way
that makes sense to your that little
seven-year-old boy
because your mom and dad probably told
you we love you and then they
disappeared on you
yeah and so your body's trying to figure
out what the crap that even means
and your journey is to figure out this
is what feeling loved feels like because
you don't know right now and that's okay
it's a skill You're Gonna Lose yeah
that's something you're gonna practice
and you're gonna get some dudes in your
life that you love and respect and iron
sharpens iron you're gonna do life with
right
okay okay hang on the line I'm gonna
send you a copy
um in fact I'm gonna send you two copies
of
um
own your past change your future my book
okay and I want you and your wife to
read it together
and highlight it this is going to give
you all a conversation I will read a
chapter a week right and we're going to
read it and we're going to talk about
what we read and what we highlighted in
it and we're going to start to
look at the little GPS pins of trauma in
our life that our bodies pegged for us
we're going to start looking at those
moments and our bodies start to feel a
little bit weird and we're going to call
a counselor
we're playing a long game with this one
and dude I'm real optimistic I'm real
optimistic 30 days I expect you to email
me back Justin to let me know I made 30
days
and then we'll do 30 days again after
that but we're going to do 30 days to
start off with why because you're a guy
that takes care of himself you're the
guy that stewards his body you're a guy
that stewards his marriage
and we're going to start there creating
a new Justin moving forward